hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen video hier
im blog messzeitraum auf meinem kanal
heute wird es natürlich wieder ein ganz
typisches blockes video geben
allerdings muss ich meine mütze ist
riesengroß und mein gott ich brauch
weihnachts kopfschmuck moment habt ihr
mein streamen gestern gesehen es hat
sehr viel spaß gemacht wir haben eine
weihnachtskarte gestaltet also ich habs
auf photoshop versucht und dann hat mir
eine zuschauerin eine viel bessere
version geschickt und ja die login
dann hab ich sie den druck geben lassen
und jetzt müssen wir nur darauf warten
dass sie endlich ankommt ich möchte dann
auch noch so ein wachs siegel kaufen
weil mir dass alle in den chat
geschrieben haben das ist cool ist und
ich werde heute den tannenbaum aufbauen
ich habe ja schon auch instagram und auf
überall gesagt ja ich weiß nicht was für
den anbau mich haben will irgendwie
einen echten aber echte sind böse dann
bist du gleich satan wenn du einen
echten hast ich habe einen plastikbaum
den habe ich vor vier jahren oder so
gekauft aber ich wollte unbedingt echten
haben aber wir sind weihnachten noch
nicht zu hause also wäre das echt
schwachsinnig einen echten zu kochen
aber wir fragen sie lieber unsere
plastik an hätte hier und ganz ehrlich
ich hoffe das war keine spinnen drin
sind weil das die ganze zeit im keller
war also lassen sondern dachte ich so
etwas macht man dann noch ein statt
aufbau das türchen öffnet wie heute
türchen nummer 15 den wir heute wieder
rahmen essen und eine achtsamkeit karte
natürlich stilles gehen nimm dir zu
irgendeinem zeitpunkt heute zehn minuten
oder länger zeit um still zu gehen
kannst diese übungen draußen oder
drinnen durchführen bleibe während der
gesamt des gesamten vorgangs still damit
du hörst was deine gedanken
hervorbringen fährt zum beispiel ein
auto vorbei sagst du dir selbst auto
auto auto wenn du spannung in deinem
körper spürst sagst du dreimal swatch
spannung achte darauf was passiert wenn
du das tust keinen atem kein atem kein
atem
schritt 1 stelle die heizung runter
schritt 2 bauer den tannenbaum auf
einen baum
ich hoffe den tisch und stellt ihn auf
den tisch ja natürlich passte nicht
drauf und wenn ich den nehme ich da so
eine decke
[Musik]
ein auge selbst leute die mein gott ich
freue mich schon auf den tag wenn wir
uns nicht vor der kamera streiten und
alle so weil wir nie streiten nie muss
schon aufgefallen ist er relativ dünn
aussieht aber keine ahnung ich habe den
mars gekauft da die noch nicht soviel
geld das der wahren will brüssel
ja du hast du ja ok team osc was hast du
da neues bekommen dadurch ja also leute
passt auf ich habe mir die bockeloh
smartphones gekauft zeigt einfach mal
was ist das denn das ist das headset und
damit kann man virtual reality ar ikone
in virtually hier haben wir ja ja das
ist es so warm weiß würde ich es
beschreiben das ist wieso zauberer oder
eine zauberer von oz zu erwarten
[Musik]
okay das muss ich mir anschauen was er
da macht also ich bin es nicht
angebracht ich bin wieder ein gutes haus
[Musik]
für zu niedrig und der schwächere fertig
macht gekommen das ist irgendwie total
krank
ich bin so blöd ich hab die ganze nicht
aufgenommen ich habe gesagt das wird
erstmal die schlichten kugeln dranhängen
dranhängen
mein plan ist einfach dieses jahr diesen
baum so voll zu machen dass man einfach
diese lücken nicht so gut erkennt bisher
nicht das einzige problem das ich sehe
dass ich viel zu perfektionistisch bin
um solche sachen zu machen denn ich kann
mich nicht entscheiden wo ne kugel
hängen soll und wo nicht und ob sie die
band da hängen sollte doch lieber dort
die weißen kugeln hängen jetzt
wunderschön und wir gehen ganz kurz mal
wieder spielen
oh ja
[Musik]
aber meine finger sind das volk hat
einen papierflieger
[Musik]
berlin reagierte yakima nur geil
status update ja echt ein bisschen karl
der baum
sie habe ich schon schneeflocken dränge
hagen und kleine zuckerstangen an die
lichterkette und ein holz weihnachtsmann
das hat so war ja meine nächste mal für
nicht gewagt das ist ein lebkuchenhaus
ist habe ich glaube ich schon seit sechs
jahren und hängt immer wieder auf und
ich habe keine spitze und jetzt kommen
noch ganz viele neue kugeln die ich
dieses jahr geholt habe und lametta
fehlt noch und die könnte ich auch noch
nie
[Applaus]
tiere sind noch bevor dieser warum wird
so überfüllt sein ich liebe es jetzt
schon
ich hatte noch zwei in köln gekauft aber
die hat hier ausgeprägt wesentlich
aufgestellt anstatt sie mir zu schicken
sie mir zu schicken wir sehr nett
gewesen das wollte ich sagen
die habe ich auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
gekauft hat die letzten zwei bekommen
[Musik]
dies von maison wie heißt noch mal was
bringt die wir aus dem westring
adventskalender auch sehr schön dann
haben wir aus new york einen cupcake
hören weil es dort schön und das ist
sogar voll krass weil der fühlt sich der
ist auch weich und wenn man könnte ihn
halt so richtig zerquetschen da an und
das ist halt auch extrem weich macht
finden die fand ich auch so schön dies
auch aus new york
[Musik]
wollt ihr mich verarschen mal wie die so
traumhaft ich weiß sie passt überhaupt
nicht in den tannenbaum rein aber sie
ist so traumhaft auch noch eine aus new
york
die
[Musik]
die hab ich mir ausgesucht diese
einzelne hat 15 euro gekostet 13 pfund
ich finde sie wunderschön und ich bereue
es nicht gekauft habe aber trotzdem 15
oder so euro sei alter bruder für die
mutter ich glaube nächstes jahr mache
ich so für die weihnachtszeit ein
postfach aufen ihr könnt mir die
verrücktesten christbaumkugeln schenken
im laden fand ich sie irgendwie blöd
aber jetzt wenn ich sie hier so sehe
das ist dennoch wohliges bundes und ich
weiß nicht ob wir den film geschaut habt
aber alter die hat 16 pfund gekostet
dieser laden war wunderschön aber auch
so teuer
ok ich suche mal für die allen platz aus
und dann zeige ich euch das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gießen denn schlafen und harry fragte
sich warten lassen
[Gelächter]
donalds in der pop ist mein kirche
nummer sieht also dass auch noch nicht
aufgemacht
jeden tag selbst stelle natürlich stehen
naja zum dritten mal schwierig weil wir
mit seinen leuten workout war beat
selber und nach einer ordentlichen runde
bzw
ich läute erstmals scheint oder eben so
dt sandra und das haben wir heute new
york vollständige sinneswahrnehmung
führe diese übung jetzt sofort durch wo
auch immer du dich befindest halten und
blicke um dich nim bewusst alles war was
deine sinne aufnehmen was sind findest
du fühlst du dich reizüberfluteten
fühlst du dich ängstlich ja oder ganz
ruhig und nimm war wo du bist was
geschieht und wie du dich genau das war
ja ich bin hier meiner couch ich mich
ein bisschen gestresst und mühte
darum finde ich den jetzt wieder mut mal
soviel des winters herumgerannt dass die
machen aber die erste woche block bis
hat gut zu tun
da hab ich und auch auch in köln ich
habe mich auch schon ganze gewundert
warum ich mich am tag müde fühle er dann
so am abend damit erschöpft aber nicht
so und wir wollten kekse bleiben nur ist
jetzt ein paar schon kannst du fragt sie
warum müde bist es 11 uhr ein gefühl von
leichtigkeit
es war viel und was klingt wie kranken
mann war es ja auch noch
wer dennoch selber gespielt mainz habe
ich leider nicht gefilmt wird wie eine
kranke geschrien und was wir machen
könnten ist schon mal eine ladung
plätzchen backen und essen morgen
dekorieren mama zu plätzchen
[Musik]
die verschwörer wird den wir dem display
laden gekauft die papier häuser von ikea
sängerische geil weil diese das licht
durchscheinen lassen also ich finde das
ganze reihe das liegt hier auch bei
dieser makro modus macht mich fertig
sieht so gut aus
na na na na na
[Musik]
heiß laufen mein gott das hättest du
heute morgen auf machen müssen
du machst ab sofort seine türen wieder
morgens auflaufen ich ja heute wollte
ich mir die eislaufen gehen ja analog
der internet
[Musik]
wir machen ja richtig rein geschissen
wir müssen jetzt schon bisher unter
brennen wie soll das denn funktionieren
das war unser adventskranz oder events
kramer voll gefreut yamaha die schöne
köpfte aber hey leute bekommt einer
neuen folge
wie schmeckt und heute machen wir die
kekse aus alice im wunderland machen wir
nicht also wir nehmen das rezept das
auch mit der kerze ja wir benutzen unser
kochbuch was wir beide zusammen gemacht
haben und zwar dass er wie schmeckt's
kochbuch hier gibt es nämlich ein ganz
fantastisches gleiche diesen wurde das
ist aber auch übel franz fantastisches
keksrezepte und zwar dringend
was für eine tolle seite für die neue
perspektive der küche habe auch
schlechtes licht über ein für alle
erstmal müssen wir den teufel eingeben
oder zucker und vanille extrakt in einer
schüssel mit handgeräten zu einer
glatten masse findet unfall erschreckend
wenn man erstmal nicht so bewusst wie
viel butter war nicht mal in dieser
anderen
donalds koki irgendwie 700 kalorien oder
so zudem dass wir hätten
weihnachtsmützen anziehen sollen zum
parken
meine vorstellung ist auch backen und so
immer so schön da macht man sonst so
sehr arbeit mehl backpulver und salz in
einer zeit nach und nach zu einer mutter
marcelle zugeht
okay da war das röhren werden
die kamera was gemacht
zwei teelöffel backpulver gerade den
himmel sowie deren support megawatt
schlüpften einfach
[Musik]
ich war jetzt mal das klingt nicht
pizzateig ist dass man die nicht so dr
muss jetzt für eine halbe stunde im
kühlschrank und vanessa zuschaut und da
mein zuhause videos von der serbe wartet
mit dieser kriegst du überhaupt kein
benzin deshalb nennt man das ist normal
dass ich mich mal wenden kann also anbau
muss sein
ein stern sich spannende eines lamas und
leute damals sowie shmeggs zeit bekommen
wir haben ja auf jeden fall mitgebracht
diese sehen wir die von mir alle lieb
ich erinnere mich auch einfach seine
grundschulzeit gefährt standard
christentum spielte auch kritik trifft
ja mein gott was guck mal das ist mein
bild klicken
[Musik]
die kinder einfach zeit
so die kekse sind jetzt schon alle
gepackt
der kameramann da sehen sie noch nicht
im ofen da und sind auch welche die
nicht ganz durch gebacken sind weil ich
hab zum anfang sind nicht versalzen
ich habe nämlich einen scherz gemacht
habe die ganze zeit für die kamera so
rein machen wollen und dann ja ich hab
das gefühl dass der tag so schnell
vergeht und dann ist so eins
wirklich himmlisch vorsichtig ofen aus
ja ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich noch
die kekse mache ich jetzt den block
beenden ja morgen werden die kekse
dekoriert leute endlich ist es passiert
der hsv wir haben kekse gemacht also ich
und timo hat zugeschaut möglichen
gemacht aber er wollte unbedingt die
hitze haben ich würde da nicht packen
ihr habt die kamera gehalten leute hier
mal ganz dass das stimmt dass die kamera
gehalten
es gehöre da fast geschafft hat mein
[Musik]
okay gute nacht ich merke das blog macht
mir viel mehr spaß als somit der großen
kamera zurzeit drehen
ich finde es so praktisch dass man viel
schneller alles filmen kann das sagt ja
was gefällt euch mehr das dann physik
auf ski